let's talk about Bill Nye the Science
Guy CNN brought on Bill Nye the Science
Guy yesterday to talk about the horrific
flooding that we've been seeing in
Louisiana even in more inland areas of
Louisiana as I told you that don't
typically flood that don't require home
insurance if you own a home in those
areas at least 13 people have died
60,000 or more homes have been damaged
and we've been making this a story about
climate change because that's really
what we're talking about and it's
important to distinguish between
individual weather events and broader
climate change but as I've said it
before I probably feel like a broken
record at this point when we see climate
change we are going to see more erratic
weather events the weather events
themselves are not the climate change
but it will be a sort of symptom and
consequence of climate change Bill Nighy
you could tell during this five-minute
interview there was something he wanted
to say and he was sort of holding back
and then at the end during this
interview with Chris Cuomo he drops it
and it's accusing CNN of having a
climate denying meteorologist on the air
let's take a look at the video breaking
you would not need to have a military on
the other side of the world protecting
oil fields people would not be as
motivated to set oil field fire if we
had renewable electricity here a big
issue that we see the world or the sea
hanging it over lots of part parts of
life let's are parts of life let's see
what happens in coming you know here at
CNN you have a essentially a climate
change denier meteorologist and knock
yourselves out but this is a big problem
and it's not going away a bigger
conversation for another day
Bill Nye ppreciate yep not something
we're gonna talk about today so Bill Nye
didn't mention any names but it's pretty
clear he's referring to CNN
meteorologist Chad Meyers who does have
a track record of making comments about
climate change he once said that there's
it's just very arrogant to think that
humans could actually do anything on the
planet to impact the climate etc etc
whenever I hear that the the whoa that's
a different conversation for a different
day I always think those will be the
that that will be the death
of the human race hey you know what that
conversation that's a conversation for a
different day like those facts and those
figures and all that reality every day
yeah that's another conversation another
day now in Chad Myers is defense he went
on Twitter and he actually made two
tweets about this the first one which I
will put up for you here Chad Myers said
not me moved to climate change in 2009
and then actually following that up
again with another tweet where he said
what did he say this one is not it but
anyway he added a scientist can be
swayed by data and I was so I have sort
of mixed feelings about this Rachel on
the one hand some people are saying Bill
Nye is hugely courageous he went on CNN
and he said to them you were part of the
problem you have this climate change
denier on the air at the same time you
could make the argument that Bill Nye
showed up uninformed not realizing that
Chad Meyers no longer supported those
climate change denial ideas of 2009 or
2010 hero courageous ignorant uninformed
I don't know well it's interesting
because there was an interview so he was
he was prompted in this interview but he
did say that he wished that climate
deniers there would be a lot to punish
them oh yeah yeah in another interview
exactly in another interview so would
that be a violation a free speech then
yes some people are writing to me and
they're like you know the optics are
that Bill Nye showed up and he did a
really great thing but if you actually
consider that chad myers has changed his
view on this and number two that once
bill nye called for punishment for
climate deniers and what is that i mean
that when we talk about violations of
free speech and and sort of thought
police
when I hear a punishment for climate
deniers
I understand punishment or taxation for
companies that are producing emitting
carbon into the atmosphere I sort of get
that legislatively I never got
clarification on what Bill Nye meant
Louis about a punishment for climate
deniers yeah legal punishment perhaps
not should we should we persecute them
absolutely and while he may have gone a
little overboard here been a bit
misinformed
it's he's using his celebrity and his
influence to to help fight this this
false equivalency issue that the
corporate media has when it comes to
climate change and that's massively
important if nothing else Jason can we
praise Bill Nye because by doing this he
was at least taking a risk that CNN
would blacklist him and that he wouldn't
be allowed back on and to a certain
degree is there some courage in that I'd
say certainly I mean to actually stand
up for the truth and you know it's so
easy just to go with the big doll or
money you know propaganda that's out
there and ride that wave but but back to
the other point I mean I think what he's
looking for is like a game of Thrones
esque shaming really everyone has to be
walked down the streets and everyone
yells shame at them maybe maybe that
will get them to actually realize that
you know this actually is reality I
don't know not a fine for what you say
but publicly ostracizing people I'm so
sick of this that's a different
conversation thing that we sometimes
hear on corporate media because the
conversation basically was hey what's
happening with these storms and floods
will there be more what can we do and
then the expert says well what we need
to look at is global climate change and
and CNN is arguably part of that problem
with this meteorologist oh that's a
bigger issue for another day now it's
kind of actually the issue we're talking
about today isn't it right I kind of
just feel like that's a cop-out to not
have to address a larger narrative
that's going on Warby Parker is offering
a free five day home Tryon to give you
the opportunity to check out their
glasses I personally wear Warby Parker
glasses when I'm not wearing my contact
lenses and I also started with one of
these free at home try ons of five pairs
of glasses you can get your free home
try on and support the david pakman show
at Warby Parker trialed comm slash TDP s
I don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses while the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home Tryon I was
able to pick five pairs that I liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few
big corporations that keep prices very
high like $300 for prescription glasses
high which is just insane
Warby Parker glasses start at $95 that's
what mine cost and for every pair of
glasses sold Warby Parker distributes a
pair of glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker comm
slash TDP s it costs nothing